let's try to fill in our Laplace
transform table a little bit more and a
good place to start is just to write our
definition of the Laplace transform the
Laplace transform of some function f of
T is equal to the integral from zero to
infinity of e to the minus st times our
function f of T DT that's our definition
and the very first one we solved for can
even do it on the side right here was
the Laplace transform of one just you
know we can almost view that as T to the
0 and that was equal to the integral
from 0 to infinity f of T was just 1 so
it's e to the minus s T DT which is
equal to the antiderivative of e to the
minus s T is minus 1 over s minus 1 over
s e to the minus s T and then you have
to evaluate that from 0 to infinity when
you take the limit is this term
approaches infinity this e to the minus
this becomes e to the minus infinity if
we assume s is greater than 0 so if we
assume s is greater than 0 this whole
term goes to 0 so you can end up with 0
minus this thing evaluated at 0 so when
you evaluate T is equal to 0 this term
right here becomes 1 right e to the 0
becomes 1 so it's minus minus 1 over s
which is the same thing as plus 1 over s
so the plus transform of one of just the
you know the constant function 1 is 1
over s we already solved that now let's
increment it a little bit let's see if
we can figure out the Laplace transform
of T so we could view this as T to the 0
now this is T to the 1 this is going to
be equal to the integral from 0 to
infinity of e to the minus s T times T
DT now I can tell you right now that you
know this isn't I don't have the
antiderivative of this memorize I don't
know what it is but there's a sense that
the integration by parts could be useful
because integration by parts kind of
decompose this into a simpler problem
and I always forget integrate
by parts so I'll read arrive it here in
in this purple color so if we have u
times V if we take the derivative with
respect to say T of that that's equal to
the derivative of the first times the
second function plus the first function
times the derivative of the second
function just the product rule now if we
take the integral of both sides of this
equation we get u v is equal to the
antiderivative of U prime V plus the
antiderivative of U V Prime now since we
want to apply this to an integral maybe
let's make this what we want to solve
for so you can get the integral of u V
prime is equal to we can just subtract
this from that side of the equation so
it's equal to em to switch swapping the
side so I'm just solving for this and to
solve for this I just subtract this from
that so it's equal to u V minus the
integral of U prime V so there you go
even though I have trouble memorizing
this formula it's not too hard to read
arrive as long as you remember as long
as you remember the product rule right
there so if we're going to do
integration by part it's good to define
our our V prime to be something it's
easy to take the antiderivative of
because we have to figure out V later on
and it's good to take u to be something
that's easy to take the derivative of so
let's make T is equal to R U and let's
make e to the minus st as being our v
prime if that's the case then what is
what is V well V is just the
antiderivative of that in fact we've
done it before it's minus 1 over s e to
the minus st that's V and then if we
want to figure out u prime because we're
going to figure out that later anyway u
prime is just the derivative of T that's
just equal to 1 so let's apply this
let's see so the Laplace transform of T
the Laplace transform of T is equal to
UV u is T
viii is this right here it's it's x
minus one over s e to the minus s T e to
the minus s T that's the UV term right
there and this isn't this is a definite
integral right so we're going to
evaluate this term right here from zero
to infinity and then it's minus minus
the integral minus the integral from 0
to infinity of U prime which is just 1
times V V we just figured out here is
minus let me write it in the V in these
color times minus 1 over s this is my V
right here minus 1 over s e to the minus
s T DT of that is DT DT and this let me
see if I can so let's let's see if we
can simplify this so this is equal to
let me minus T over s e to the minus s T
evaluated from 0 to infinity and then
see we can take thus well this is just 1
we could you know this 1 times anything
is 1 we can just not write that and then
bring the minus one of our s out so if
we bring the minus 1 over s out this
becomes plus 1 over s times the integral
from 0 to infinity of e to the minus s T
DT and this should look familiar to you
this is exactly what we solved for right
here it was a little applause transform
of 1 so let me let's keep that in mind
so this right here is little plus
transform of 1 and I want to write it
that way because we're going to see a
pattern of this in the next video I'm
going to write that as a plus transfer 1
but what is this equal to so we're going
to evaluate this as it add to infinity
and then subtract from that evaluated at
0 so I'm just going to make you can kind
of view it as the substitution so this
is equal to and well let me write it
this way it's limit as a approaches
infinity
of minus a over s e to the minus s a so
that's this evaluated at infinity and
then from that we're going to subtract
this evaluate at 0 so minus all of this
but we already have a minus sign here so
we could write a plus plus we could
write zero over s times e to the minus s
times 0 and then of course we have this
term right here so let me write that
term I'll do it in yellow
let me do it in blue plus 1 over s
that's this right there times the
Laplace transform of 1 and what do we
get what do we get so what's the limit
is this as a approaches infinity you
might say well you know this as a
approaches infinity right here this
becomes a really big number there's a
minus sign in there so it'd be a really
big negative number but this is going to
this is an exponent a is an exponent
right here so e to the minus infinity is
going to go to 0 much faster than this
is going to go to infinity this term
right here is a much stronger function I
guess you can the way you can see you
could try it out on your calculator if
you don't believe me this term is going
to overpower this term and so this whole
thing is going to go to 0 this whole
thing is going to go to 0 likewise e to
the minus this e to the 0 this is 1 but
you're multiplying it times a 0 so this
is also going to go to 0 which is
convenient because all of this stuff
just disappears and we're left with the
Laplace transform of t is equal to 1
over s times the Laplace transform of 1
and we know what the Laplace transform
of 1 is the Laplace transform of 1 we
just did at the beginning of the video
which is equal to 1 over s if we assume
that s is greater than 0 and in fact we
have to assume that s was greater than 0
here in order to sassoon that this goes
to 0 only if s is greater than 0 then
when you get a minus infinity here does
this approach to 0 so fair enough so
Laplace transform of T is equal to 1
over s times 1 over s which is equal to
1
s squared for s is greater than zero so
we have one more entry in our table and
then we can use this we're going to do
in the next video is build up to the
Laplace transform Laplace transform of T
to any arbitrary exponent and we'll do
this in the next video